Here's another handy
concurrency primitive.
It's a parallel for loop,
or par-for for short.
Now if you ever run off on your own to
read classic papers in the parallel
algorithms literature, you'll sometimes
see such loops described as for-any
loops or for-all loops.
So what does a par-for mean?
When you use a par-for,
you're saying that all iterations
are independent of one another.
In other words, you can execute
the iterations in any order.
To put it in DAG terms, a par-for
creates n independent sub paths.
You can think of this as executing n
independent spawns simultaneously if
such a thing were possible.
Hey, what does he mean if
such a thing were possible?
That's smells suspiciously like a quiz.
Now by convention,
the end of a par-for loop will
include an implicit sync point.
The implicit sync point will force all
of these independent paths to join.
Now suppose every iteration
has a constant cost.
That is, imagine calling foo(i)
is bounded by a constant.
If there are n iterations then
the work of a par-for is just O(n).
So what about the span?
Now in theory if all these foos have
constant cost then you would think
that the span is basically a constant.
But in practice what you should expect
to see is that the span will actually
grow with n especially
when n is really big.
If you have, say,
an electrical engineering or
circuit background,
imagine trying to build a circuit
that has 100 million paths
coming out of a gate.
So to understand this point,
I want you to think about two different
implementations of a par-for using only
spawn and sync, and see what happens.